Ryan has announced changes the LCS
broadcast schedule that I have some fans
believing it is the final nail in the
coffin for an already a declining
viewership base at the same time valent
in the VCT broadcast schedule looks a
lot like the prime time slot the LCS
used to have no parents supposed to have
a favorite child but did Riot just
reveal theirs
[Music]
hey y'all it's Liz just a reminder that
we still have merch available with the
link in the description below personally
you all know I love the cream hoodie but
also I love everything else
I don't have a favorite child I'm not
like Riot riot games small Indie company
mostly known for their Flagship title
League of Legends you might have heard
of it you might have seen us including
yours truly attend worlds this year you
know just one of the biggest Esports
events in the world here let's play a
game name your top three Esports
professionals I am willing to bet in
your top three you included Faker League
of Legends Legend the point I am trying
to make and honestly I don't think I
have to make it is that League of
Legends is one of the biggest Esports in
the world the esport has created the
best matches memories and players for
literally millions of people but there
has been discussions at the LCS or the
North American Circuit of League of
Legends is dying as Sabrina on for early
game wrote sure the play wasn't always
top tier with teams like TSM barely
making it out of groups at international
events but at least the region had
personality and charm which led people
to tune in and watch the season again
but it seems that there are less and
less viewers each split there was a
report in October that Riot would be
moving LCS broadcasts to weekdays
instead of the weekend like they had
been the most important thing is that we
didn't know the times of broadcast
until December in December 2022 Wright
officially announced that they would be
revamping their broadcast schedule to
better serve fans hold on to the better
served fans part because people have
thoughts on that they announced that the
LCS arena is being renamed to the riot
games Arena and that beginning with
spring split 2023 the LCS will shift its
primary broadcast days to Thursdays and
Fridays starting at 3 pm Eastern or noon
for all U.S Coast folk the Visa T
Americas on the other hand will be
Saturday Sunday Monday starting at noon
PST AKA 3 P.M for us East Coasters if
this doesn't sound like a big deal to
you the LCS has always held the prime
time slot AKA weekend afternoons
evenings now the BCT Americas has that
now why would Riot make such a decision
it wasn't that long ago that saying the
LCS is dying was a Blasphemous statement
now you're a famous League personalities
like doublelift saying that verbatim
look guys LCS is dying like the
viewership is absolutely dying it's
there's no there's no denying everyone
knows everyone can feel it according to
Riot this move needed to happen for a
variety of reasons they say that a deep
dive they commissioned confirmed for
them that among other things Peak
viewing times move to match the changing
Lifestyles for our fans and that moving
the broadcast to weekdays will bring
more fans in they explained that they
came to this conclusion by disclosing
their findings first sets fans follow
games rather than regions so like a
league fan from North America would
rather watch the LEC rather than VCT
Europe next they discover that fans want
to watch big matches and their favorite
teams so Danny Burke of the score
Esports is there for TSM and whatever
juicy matchup there is perhaps
doublelifts return to Pro play lastly
they say they want to Pace their
broadcasts because fans were fatigued
after a full day of League of Legends
Esports the demand for Content that is
equal for the weekdays and weekends and
picking what to watch can be a chore I'm
not sure why that last one is literally
our fans have to make decisions
sometimes but not my article but if you
look at some responses from parts of the
community some fans really don't agree
you guys keep reaffirming and reassuring
people that weekdays are good but that
that's not the change anyone has a
problem with it's the time it's at start
it later not at noon PT in my opinion
weekdays are totally fine but the time
slot seems ill-suited for a North
American audience I've watched nearly
every game of LCS for the past four
years I'm going to struggle when the
start is in the middle of the work day
maybe I'm not the target audience
anymore there were also concerns on not
only is Right making the LCS pretty
inaccessible for fans but they're also
playing favorites by giving their
weekend prime time slot to none other
than their sister product valorent
basically a lot of people said that
while weekdays are fine a lot of people
don't have the time to watch competitive
League of Legends in the middle of the
day if there are concerns that the LCS
needs better viewership I completely
understand if you look at the viewership
it is not an unreasonable thing to say
the peak viewers average viewers and
hours watch have had a noticeable
decrease from Summer 2020 to Summer 2022
with pretty much the exact same air time
weather that is hyperbolic or not a lot
of people feel that having your
broadcast at the same time as their
their work schedule or their school
schedule is not exactly going to do
wonders for declining viewership it just
doesn't seem like the right move but
those same fans can watch valorent
because most of them don't have work or
school so he knew seemingly inaccessible
time and another show that got the prime
time slot if you're an LCS fan seeing
all this I'm not surprised at all by
your disappointment or anger I watch
professional wrestling on the weeknights
right if aw Dynamite airs at 3 pm I
probably couldn't watch it I wouldn't
watch it not even for Kenny Omega but
for a konosuke takashta I will drop
everything to get that man some Cinnabon
after work when I have time in my
opinion as our average VCT consumer is
that this doesn't feel right like okay
me as a Valor fan if valerian's on the
weekends that reads to me that the data
shows that that's our best block cool
whatever Riot claiming that the data for
the LCS shows that the best time is for
weekdays and midday but for the VCT it's
weekends afternoons
just seems wrong listen I don't have the
numbers I didn't commission the Deep
dive or whatever but we can't be that
different in our consumption habits
we're all anti-social nerds at the end
of the day also to the point that Raya
is picking Valor and as their favorite
Esports product I have to disagree would
Riot a business that has to make money
make a decision that would make the LCS
have less exposure less success less
money on purpose like they have no
reason to not want the LCS to thrive
like I genuinely believe that Riot
believes that this is the move to
breathe life back into the LCS I'm not
saying it's the correct move I'm just
saying I can't get behind the idea of
favoritism in one of their biggest
Esports Travis Gafford echoed similar
sentiments in his YouTube video about
this I don't know how else to say it but
Riot has a lot of incentives to keep LCS
alive they don't have any incentives for
this thing to die so like as much as and
again I don't blame you because they've
done not a great job of just waiting
people from this but
please please trust me when I say that
like they want LCS to thrive they want
it to grow they want to restore it to
the procedure that it used to have
Travis also talked about the lack of
trust the LCS fans have in Riot and if
you are a fan and you feel like you are
an afterthought or just not being cared
for then yeah I completely get it if
you're confused join the party and pull
up a chair we have lots of snacks and
anxiety over here my question today is
for the LCS fans in the audience are you
watching the spring split can you watch
it do you feel like an afterthought I
mean this With all sincerity I hope you
can watch it in the most comfortable way
possible
listen
if this if konosuke takeshita sees this
I need to look my best okay bro who's
got you smiling like that it's kind
of no I have to like speak to him the
end board I have to be like hey konosuke
you're wrestling tonight I don't
remember if it's live
good luck I'm rooting for you I'll get
you some Cinnabon let me know I'm So
Smooth
is it hot it's really hot